You have probably heard of the high
to late medieval guilds that existed
all across Europe. If you have not,
then I made a video about that.
However, the complicated structure of the high
and late medieval period occupation guilds like
merchant guilds, or craft guilds, evolved
from a much more simpler style of guild that
emerged in the early medieval period. Due
to this simpler structure of, oftentimes,
non-occupation-centric guilds
of the early medieval period
some historians call these early guilds
‘gilds’ as to differentiate the two.
A gild is an organization of multiple members
often, but not always, with a founding charter
or a formal agreement and a swearing of oaths,
that was set up in a horizontal structure with
certain goals in mind. These goals could
be anything from a simple drinking club
to trying to lower the crime rate in
a city by policing it. These gilds,
in pursuing their founding goals, could
act in collaboration with the state
and or the church, or be independent
from them, or even act against them.
How these early medieval gilds formed is hard
to say as there are limited sources on them,
and the interpretation of those
sources usually depends on how a
historian views the migration period and
the fall of the Western Roman Empire.
To explain, there are two major historical
interpretations of the migration period and its
outcome. These two interpretations are described
by Halsall as ‘Movers’ and ‘Shakers’. To quote
“Movers believe that the changes of late
antiquity may be ascribed to the movement
into the Roman Empire of largely Germanic
barbarians; the barbarians, viewed as numerically
significant migrating ‘peoples', are at least the
catalyst for change. Shakers, on the other hand,
believe that tensions and changes within the
Roman Empire were already shaking it to its core,
and the barbarians, usually seen as small,
elite warrior groups were but a symptom,
if perhaps a focus, of these changes.“ Of course
not all historians fall neatly into these two
categories and there's much more nuance to it but
all you need to know for this video is that there
are these two interpretations of the migration
period and the fall of the Western Roman Empire.
So with that said, historians who prefer
the ‘shakers’ interpretation largely see
the early medieval gilds as stemming
from, if not directly connected to,
the late Roman collegia. The collegia were Roman
institutions closely resembling, in structure,
the well known occupation guilds of the high to
late middle ages. They functioned as social clubs,
religious collectives, trade unions, and even
sometimes as lobbying bodies. They were basically
collective institutions that could act as legal
entities which could hold property or sue other
people/institutions. They often sprang up in urban
centres and could in reality be doing anything;
there were collegia of grave diggers
and marchants, as well as of cultists
and religious institutions. These collegia
also survived well into the Middle ages,
in a bit of a different form, in the Eastern Roman
Empire or, in other words, the Byzantine Empire,
but I won't mention them as I am
talking about the west in this video.
The proponents of the ‘movers’ interpretation
talk about the early medieval gilds as either
stemming from older Germanic practices
or being independently created within the
newly formed early medieval Germanic kingdoms
after the Roman tradition of collegia died out.
Hence the early medieval gilds have
no connection to the Roman collegia.
Neither of these two theories on the origins
of the early medieval gilds can be proven
at the moment as not much research
has been done into the topic and no
source has been discovered that would
outright prove or disprove one or the other.
With that said, early medieval gilds still
existed so let's look at what they were and
what they did. The early medieval gilds, unlike
their later counterparts, weren’t centered around
an occupation. Meaning the gilds that were formed
in the early medieval Germanic kingdoms weren’t
guilds of solely merchants, or cobblers, or
blacksmiths, etc. These gilds, rather than
occupation, had largely geographical separations.
Meaning anyone within the geographical area of the
gilds operation could, in theory, join the gild
if they wanted to, no matter what their occupation
was; and I do mean anyone. Early medieval gilds,
even though largely consisting of a free urban
class, also included surfs, clergymen, lower level
aristocrats, and even women which is unusual given
the nature of later medieval guilds which often
outright banned women in any participation.
Firstly, I’ll mention what I call protection
or military gilds but are also called ‘peace
gilds’. The goal of some early medieval gilds
involved some kind of mutual protection,
sometimes with a fairly militaristic
character. The most famous of these
protection gilds were London's Frith Gilds of
the 10th century. They were established by “a
group of like minded individuals who kept law
and order within the community instead of relying
solely on the support of the local sheriff or
alderman.” London wasn’t the only place where
these kinds of gilds were established nor were
these kinds of gilds unique to urban centres,
similar gilds were established across the
Frankish lands in rural areas. These gilds
were a form of people’s organized law and order
enforcement, often in places where the state,
in other words the king, was unable to
provide sufficient enough protection.
Speaking of providing sufficient enough
protection. Just like the protection gilds
of London, you. yourself, should consider your
own online protection with NordVPN. NordVPN is a
simple to use VPN service with over 5200 servers
in 60 different countries. You want to watch
something that is unavailable in your country, no
problem, NordVPN has got you covered. You want to
play a game that is geo-restricted, no problem,
with NordVPN not only can you play the game but
also, thanks to their new NordLynx feature and
the fact that they’re upgrading to 10 gigabit
per second servers, you’re also not gonna suffer
as much lag spikes. NordVPN can be downloaded on
6 different devices with one subscription and
is available for all major operating systems.
So to protect yourself in the digital
world go to nordvpn.com/laserhistory
and use the coupon code laserhistory to get a
2-year plan plus 4 months hugely discounted.
If you feel like not typing all that out, no
problem, just click the link at the top of the
description or in the pinned comment. Thank you
so much to NordVPN for sponsoring this video.
Going back to protection gilds,
some kings embraced these gilds,
like, for example, the London ones which got
officially recognized by King Aethelstan,
but other protection gilds weren’t
as lucky and got cracked down upon,
sometimes very harshly. This was because
they were often viewed by kings as a form of
unsanctioned vigilantism and or threats to royal
authority within the area of their operation.
For example, when the peasants of the Loire
valley established a protection gild in the
9th century against Viking raids from which
king Odo of France was unable to protect them,
they were quote ‘massacred’ by the king for
daring to establish an institution that was
unsanctioned by him and, according to him,
competed with his authority in the area.
Lastly the most militaristic example of these
protection gilds were the Saxon ‘companion’ gilds.
This kind of gild emerged in the Duchy
of Saxony after it was incorporated into
the Frankish Empire in 804. It was a sort of
military institution of free-man and peasants
that preceded the ‘men at arms’ of the high
middle ages. They acted as a protection force,
as a raiding force, as a policing force, and
also as a military political force. For example,
the Saxon ‘companion’ gilds helped emperor Lothar
1st in a war against his brother Luis the German.
To some these military gilds may seem more
like roaming bands of soldiers than actual
gilds but despite their militaristic and often
bandit nature, the ‘companion’ gilds were still
institutions that resembled gilds in almost every
way. They held meetings, collected fees, elected
officials, and had set goals in mind, plus their
militaristic nature was by far not unique as even
later medieval guilds like the Hansa could and
did go to war, sometimes against entire kingdoms.
Next I’ll talk about the most common type of
gilds in the early middle ages, religious gilds.
These gilds were divided between ones formed by
clergymen and ones by common people, of course
an overlap between the two existed. The religious
gilds created by clergymen were formed as sort of
discussion clubs where clergymen could meet for
meals in either gild halls or other predetermined
meeting places, discuss their ministry, theology,
and get help preparing sermons. On the other hand,
the religious gilds formed by common people were
sort of prayer groups largely connected with a
parish church, and often established by wealthy
individuals like Barons or Bishops. The goal of
these ‘lay’ religious gilds for the participants
was to become more connected to the church and
become more attuned with god but their duty was
also to pray for the lives of their founder/patron
and his family. This was not unusual in the middle
ages. Many wealthy people established or funded
hospitals, abbies, monasteries, collegies, and
religious gilds in order that they have people
praying for them and their family. It was a sort
of religious investment or insurance to make
sure that even if you did something sinful
you balanced it out with your investments.
On the other side of the spectrum from
the religious gilds you had social gilds
or drinking gilds. These pretty much acted as
what we would today call fraternities or eating
clubs. Members would contribute to a common fund,
officers would be chosen to govern the proceedings
and manage assets, wealthier gilds would use their
assets to buy/build gild halls for their events,
and some swearing of oaths, and or rituals, and or
hazing of new members could have been conducted.
These kinds of early social gilds also often
acted as insurance cooperatives where members
of the gilds swore to pay for each other's
legal proceedings when they got in trouble,
or compensate each other in case of a house
fire, or pay for each other's funerals when
a gild member died, etc. Social/drinking gilds
weren’t liked by the church much because as one
clergyman the Alcuin of York wrote complaining to
the Archbishop of canterbury in the 8th century
“[these] curious meetings, which
they are accustomed to have and call
gilds … were seducing people away from
prayer in church, and leading them instead
to drunken parties in surrounding hills,
thereby undermining epsicopal authority”.
Naturally the descriptions of the different types
of gilds I gave in this video are simplifications
of a much more complicated reality. All
early medieval gilds were unique with often
ever changing goals and members and therefore my
general overview of these gilds will not always
100% apply to any specific individual gild. On top
of that, the main three gild types I talked about
could and often did have large overlaps;
protection gilds had a fairly large social
character to them, while social/drinking gilds
often had a very religious aspect to them with
members being required to conduct frequent
prayers, and some religious gilds could have
fairly wild social events. According to one source
“Priests [in gilds] had been attending raucous
parties, either alone or with laymen, where
they drank to the saints or to their own souls,
got into fights and told stories to rowdy
applause; others indulged in entertainments
involving bears and dancing girls, or even
demonic masks.“ Take this quote with a pinch
of salt however. This source comes from
an archbishop who was arguing against the
existence of religious gilds and therefore his
account is an over-exaggeration, but it does go
to show that the events of religious gilds could
have possibly gotten quite debaucherous sometimes.
From these early medieval gilds of Western Europe
evolved the later, and much more well known,
occupation guilds. For example, the job of the
London peace gilds eventually got taken over by
London Livery companies, which were essentially
occupation guilds. The specific social gilds that
acted more like insurance cooperatives
evolved into merchant or craft guilds which,
on top of other things, still insured members
assets and still kept a very strong social dynamic
reminiscent of the early social gilds, just watch
my Life of a Hansa Merchant video to see just how
strong these social aspects of the later medieval
guilds were. With that said, just like with the
early medieval gilds and collegia it is actually
still debated whether the later occupation guilds
did develop from these earlier simpler gilds.
However, considering that some of these early
medieval gilds existed until the 11th and 12th
century, which is the same time when the first
occupation guilds started to form, I think it is
safe to say that even if not directly connected,
the early medieval gilds created a social
institution which formed the bases upon which
the later more economically focused and powerful
occupation guilds, like the Hansa, were created.
Before I say anything thank you to NordVPN for
sponsoring this video. Ehh, so far it has been
a rough 2021 for me, hence the lack of videos but
hopefully that will change now. I know I said that
before but like I am trying, it doesn’t always
work out sometimes. However, my next video is
a banger. I have worked on it for almost a year
now, so look forward to that. Other than that I
have to give extremely large thanks to
my Patreons and my members on YouTube,
who’s financial support has been extremely
helpful this year, thank you so much. Ehmm
other than that, my name is M.
Laser and stick around for history.